we have another running segment in the
emails where people sent in photos of
things that are supposed to be meant for
children boys and girls are supposed to
enjoy these things but then we look at
them and say these are inappropriate
toys
[Music]
kay Coughlin from Buffalo New York sent
this one and he said this is at the
kittyland at our local amusement park in
Buffalo remember the part of the story
of Alice in Wonderland where she grows
too big for the house she eats the
cookie yeah I for a while I lived that
part of the book he's got too big for
the house yeah they take a wall out and
[ __ ] then call that Dick Gregory old
school slayed me thank you
sometimes they do [ __ ] just for you
thank you I appreciate it
Alice got so big her arms or legs are
all sticking out through the windows and
stuff so and this low-rent kitty park in
Buffalo they tried to replicate that but
they used that as the staging area for
their puppet show so the place where
they put on the puppet show with Alice
sticking her limbs out of the house
isn't necessarily appropriate for kids I
don't think I don't think you want to
put on a show and Alice's vagina when
she gets too big for the house it's
literally a shadow box I don't see Punch
and Judy coming out of her vajayjay
Frank Palmer from Columbus Ohio sent in
this one remember when we were kids they
would have these guns that you could put
little with yellow plastic pellets in
and yeah they weren't as bad as like BB
guns they were like soft plastic oh the
projectile thing yeah they were plastic
yeah apparently they got outlawed
because I don't know some kid lost his
vision or something [ __ ] [ __ ]
so ruined it for the rest of exactly so
they went out of fashion for a while but
they're coming back into fashion because
they've now using these gel balls
they're called it's sort of a
fluid-filled pustule of fun somehow and
they fire it out of guns and kids use it
now and it's not ideal I guess still to
this day but apparently is more soft and
more safe for the kids this is one of
those that Frank Palmer found on a kids
website and a cat
an online catalog he thinks for whatever
reason it might be inappropriate for
kids I don't know you tell me
oh my lord no need to shoot blanks
anymore kid no and how is that not like
a silly-string shooter by the way how is
that why is it pellets I don't know why
the pellets are blue they should be
pearly white that's right and it was
recently the 4th of July Independence
Day here in the United States and Mathew
Corbin sent in this inappropriate toy he
said I was buying fireworks this week
and I saw this immediately thought of
Ralph you know i'm i've got a ongoing
battle with this culture that creates
the poop toys that poop now is the the
the most popular theme for kids to play
with
this was a firework for kids to play
with based on poop it was called the
poopy puppy and if you light the poops
[ __ ] if you like the puppies [ __ ]
apparently something magical was
supposed to happen so i have a little
video of the poopy puppy in action and
you can see just why they call this
firework the poopy puppy for kids right
now
I forgot about that part what what that
was that at the end it's an explosion at
the end it's a firework and I hope that
[ __ ] guy lost a finger because he's
an [ __ ] with the blue pee puppy does
it's like those little snakes we used to
have when we were kids you lighten it
just grew same premise apparently genius
but now it's called the poopy puppy
because poop is the newest thing that
all the kids love to play with that is
adding a spoke to the wheelman that that
that is human ingenuity that like what
could improve this a [ __ ] dog
[Music]
you
[Music]